what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we're gonna watch
ourselves Gravity Falls today
uh something episode it's loading on our
Disney Plus account right now but what
do we say here John we say that you
should leave a like on the video of
course and what else do we say oh and
maybe subscribe and hit the notification
Bell and then where can they watch the
full interaction wash along so they sync
up with their own copy easy
patreon.com the real rejects got a bunch
of shows over there with three action
highlights and watch alongs included and
who else is edit these down it's prepper
the team over there lots of people on
the team what episode is this it's
season two episode 15 the last map look
horn yeah there we go all right another
go
foreign
[Music]
Bros whoa
I know that laugh show yourself no
he's had many encounters with him
aren't you a sight for sore eye Stanford
philbrick Pines my old pal Bill Cipher
what do you want from me you son of a
[ __ ] IQ you knew I'd be back if things
shutting down that portal you stop what
I have planned I've been making deals
chatting with old friends preparing for
the big day you're out of the deal maybe
not right now but things change Stanford
finds things
[Applause]
I have to warn them he's coming
they've encountered him before they
could defeat him again yeah Cipher ain't
so tough short intro substantial episode
Necronomicon Appley don't wake stylish
eat it hey what's this what could go
wrong in the board game looks like them
open this box never made it out alive
well I guess they know what we take up
the next 21 minutes
better all right Santiago you have 24
hours to get these pugs across the U.S
border family
Octavio are you going to tell us we're
finally of age to go to Wizard School
sure you if there's an owl in this bag
he's long dead
yikes either of you recognize this
symbol he's been terrorizing us all
summer and if he pulls off his plans no
one in this family will be safe their
hairs can only be obtained by a pure
good-hearted person who goes on a
magical quest to find
yes my first word was unicorn I once
made my own unicorn by taping a traffic
cone to a horse's head are you even
looking at the sweater I'm wearing right
Dimensions I didn't notice that it won't
be easy take this and this I haven't
been in this dimension for a while it's
okay to give children weapons right come
on Doc of course it is so what are the
odds she gets that hair unlikely I've
dealt with unicorns before and if I had
to describe them in one word it would be
frustrating
welcome to my private study a place
where I keep my most ancient and secret
knowledge even your uncle Stan doesn't
know about this planet come along
what was that painting
are about my friends honestly I stopped
believing in unicorns when I was like
five years old I'm just coming along to
keep you kids from walking into a bear
trap stop is that a stark shirt summon
the Unicorn when my bellow this ancient
chant droned only by the deepest voiced
Druids of old
I bet you ten bucks nothing happens I'll
take that bet Ah that's authentic throat
singing You're gonna be broke Wendy
[Music]
[Music]
and on every girl's binder in the 90s
is that Lisa Frank
no way
huh
God damn right
[Music]
visitors to my realm of Enchantment oh
no it's okay it's protein unicorn can
see
it's your heart child
I'll have to enroll guess I do make fun
of Dipper a lot and I did just shatter a
window with a crossbow
she's right I used to be one of the
sweetest people I knew today we're gonna
fix it from this moment forth I'm gonna
do so many good deeds I'll have the
pierced heart and Gravity Falls oh no
did you get his hands on this Rift he
would trick or possess anyone so how do
we keep bill out of our mind I
personally had a metal plate installed
in my head good one
well scan your mind bioelectrically
encrypting your thoughts so Bill can't
read say hello to your thoughts oh man I
can't believe I'm with the author might
fly down
by the way you never told me what your
history with Bill was do you trust me
well yeah but then you'll trust that
that's not important it's time to
strengthen your mind
did he create bill it's time to
strengthen your heart
[Music]
when that unicorn scans my heart she's
gonna say I'm absolutely 100 bona fide
not purify you were doing Deeds to gain
something
they were not selfless
those are basically children's dreams
it's not my fault you're a bad person oh
now if you'll excuse me I have a three
o'clock posing in front of a rainbow
[Applause]
oh
Bill Cipher have something to do with
this I'm not a good person who am I I'm
not leaving this spot until I think of a
deed that makes me as good as Celeste
developed bethabelle just leave me be
you gotta kill that unicorn Mabel's like
the best person I've ever met we tried
getting that hair the good way now it's
time we try the Wendy way are you
suggesting violence sabotage
sabotage it's time we stop trying to be
so perfect and be who we really are
we're crazed angry sweaty animals we're
not unicorns we're women and women
yes
[Music]
too much nope
I'm looking for someone who knows how to
take down a unicorn no tricks or games
we are human we take what we want yeah
fairy dust
I like butterflies they tickle my face
and make me laugh bring me a bag of
butterflies and we got a deal
No Man's Land bag's a fairy dust just
like we agreed where do you get this
stuff everyone lacks sausage but no one
likes to know how it's made you've got
your poison I've got mine yeah well the
deal is up
whoa butterflies aren't man I swear I've
been framed tell it to the adorable owl
we've dressed as a judge my cut
[Music]
what the heck
SOS
it was dark
yeah they just chloroformed somebody
whoa whoa whoa you gotta be kidding me
huh yo sea Beth Are you seriously
pulling this pure of heart scam again
that is messed up man
foreign
yeah the whole pure of heart racket is
just a line we use to get humans to
leave us alone
all this time all this time
you're even worse than I am kill the
Unicorn well chicks okay we
have to ourselves just to take humans
off what are you gonna do about it huh
huh what are you gonna do oh yeah
oh
my God
[Applause]
ah use the machine it'll show you his
thoughts I shouldn't he won't know he's
going to tell you eventually the more
you know about Bill the more you can
help man I am really good at rationalize
that's not your that's not your
monologue who are you working with my
brother is a dangerous know-it-all he
would trick or possess anyone then it's
a deal from now until the end of time
just let me into your mind Stanford
please call me a friend
oh no
you shouldn't have done that
oh holy [ __ ]
that's a reveal bill could possess
anyone so he could get this careful hand
me the rift he's got the evil anime
glasses I'll erase you right out of
fort's head it's me Dipper it's your
uncle there's no one trust no one just
hand it to me
it's okay Dipper besides my mind can't
be erased anyway remember
if that really was Bill though you would
have done great I should have been more
like you I don't trust you ancient
incantations about a being with answer
it warned me not to read them but I was
desperate I read the inscription aloud
but nothing happened until later that
afternoon when I had the most peculiar
dream were you name Bill and your name's
Stanford Pines the man who changed the
world have a cup of tea he chose one
brilliant mind a century to inspire he
was free to move in and out of my mind
as he pleased we were Partners
fascinating it was on the verge of my
greatest achievement
[Music]
until my partner got a glimpse of Bill's
true plan bill you lied to me where does
that portal really lead
oh looks like Mr Brainiac
that when that portal finishes charging
up your dimension is gonna learn how to
party right guys
no I'll stop you I'll shut it down yikes
all he needs to do is get his hands on
this Rift to us it would mean the end of
our world
so embarrassed about earlier I'm such an
idiot embarrassed you needed to do that
no actually oh that would have been
perfect either way we got some unicorn
hair
Acorn eyelash
es they finally gave us this treasure
just to get rid of us
with this unicorn hair we'll be able to
completely Shield The Shack from Bill's
mind reading trick better than okay it's
perfect you've protected your family
you're a good person Mabel oh
pure of heart today I learned that
morality is a relative
[Laughter]
as long as we're inside our minds are
safe I guess I
was like that he went inside the shack
to have to find my next Pawn on the
outside
no
who would Zeus yeah oh sus would be the
worst it'll be so heartbreaking
right he's kind of triangular he can
possess him and then go inside right
uh that's a good question but but I bet
that's worth a try what are the rules
yeah will he be ejected upon Susie's
attempt to enter
that's a crazy reveal yeah
it was a cyber he carries bill with him
everywhere he goes
Bill's been corrupting Bill's been a
part of this the entire time
it all goes back to Bill
is The Wizard of Oz
behind the curtain toiling I like the
way Bill Cipher's written you can see
how Charming he is
like his little Wise Cracks all the time
too yeah hey how's it going
you know coming up heels here I don't
know why it's good
you must be Green With Envy
it's good because you're wearing a green
shirt and Bill's got an intense
knowledge and power so you would be
envious of that yeah yeah you sound
confident I always do
it's confidence voice right there
confidence voice
yeah I really like that uh I like that
episode and I thought the B story might
have been annoying at first but it
wasn't
it was amusing that unicorn man messed a
unicorn up once in a while sure you know
what I mean especially yeah
and they're like oh it wasn't really a
lesson to be learned
sometimes morality is relative and
anybody who's trying to put you through
a morality test might not be the most
moral person sometimes you just get
pushed to the edge and you know whoop
some ass yeah sometimes you gotta be
absolutely direct but to discover the
unicorns and
to have a
a little flavor there that was super
whimsical
that might have been frustrating and
annoying surprisingly did not turn that
way yeah I actually thought it was
really funny and
um I don't know I wish we saw the whole
unicorn fight actually that punch the
first time she punched unicorn was
surprisingly violent to me I was like oh
I feel that it was punched a horse in
the face yeah it's bleeding his nose and
and it's blood like Withers plants
so like there is something innately it's
like even though it's rainbow colored
you still feel it a little bit and I
like the relationship as it develops
with Ford and Dipper because you know
Dipper and and um
Stan have always been at odds with each
other in weird ways or things like they
maybe do like their their uh their care
can go so up and down they can go
frustrated with each other especially on
Dipper's end but here is the person he
can like really look up to and admire
and confide in and relate to the most
and so does when you watch their bond
develop it there's a bit of a
it's not Rick and Morty but a little bit
more like Doc Brown and Marty in some
ways yeah I absolutely like that and I
like that they I like the way they let
the intensity play where you really kind
of do lose the line and I I thought the
trick with the reflective like Sinister
anime glasses was a good one too because
it's partly about being in Dipper's
perspective and you're like hey like
Stanford is clever and you always have
to be like skeptical of people who are
clever in a cleverness game and so
without the experience we've had with
Bill before and then creating that
paranoia of like wait a minute he won't
tell me stuff but he's like scanning my
whole brain right now I was like oh wow
like yeah they I was teetering with you
because I was like I don't know man
maybe he is maybe maybe this is all one
big Ploy in ruse to get everybody right
what they want because maybe Stanford
and uh Bill are essentially now one in
the same but I I I like the the way they
resolved that because it seems like he's
mostly you know yeah he's good he's on
the up and up but you still have those
little like uh inklings of I don't know
this could go wrong this could be
dismantled somehow you feel the stakes
so
um
bill is like the main bad guy yeah like
if there was a central bad guy to
Gravity Falls it would be bill seems as
though because that was never really
clear to me it's like he was one of the
reoccurring of one of the bigger baddies
but considering this all stems a lot of
the big biggest problems Gravity Falls
has had yeah stems back to him yeah
because without him I think a lot of the
things that the the strange creatures
and occurrences in Gravity Falls not be
what they are oh yeah the whole portal
opening he influenced his mind the whole
time in order to create it yeah yeah
absolutely it's like it all can be
traced back to him even if he is just
kind of jaunting along and and playing
games and and you know amusing himself
that's an eye-opener sure yeah he's been
behind it all single eye-opener it's
right
third eye opener wow John well they got
a closing thought
um you know
don't worry about being pure of heart do
what you want punch a unicorn take a
tear bring it home every once in a while
you gotta punch a [ __ ] unicorn man
every once again you gotta punch
something magical and Majestic punch
unicorn
to-do list after a covet test yeah yeah
make sure you don't get that unicorn
sick
thank you do you guys know where uh any
unicorns are around here
I gotta go I gotta go punch it before I
go back back home yeah you should get
that out of your system
I've punched many horses it's not the
same there's something horses really not
there's so many horsepower and once you
get through the variety of different
colors and sizes then you're like what
am I doing man I need to level up most
zebras can I punch back I know you gotta
behind them so they can kick you and
that's even like you know it's hard to
be like okay wait come over here now
it's pathetic yeah I've punched many
horses you ever punched a zebra
wanted to
I got this close oh this close chicken
down I did I got nervous at the last
minute yeah the stripes that's what the
stripes are for yeah let you out make
you question yourself as a predator I
mean Will Smith already took care of
that for us oh yeah sure
you get it figure out the joke John
figure it out figure out the joke come
on zebra joke with Will Smith slapping
him keep my wife's name out of your no
come on come on did you guys get it
already
did you guys do it
come on figure it out Will Smith in the
zebra Will Smith did not punch
a zebra he punched a rock
uh the zebra connection
uh zebras and rocks Chris Roxy but oh
Madagascar yes he's the zebra in the
movie I definitely have seen and c and
I'm not only referencing due to my
knowledge of the trailers that's right
he plays whatever the zebra's name is I
guess opposite Ben Stiller's Melman the
lion yeah and the Penguins I understand
and and who plays the hippo Queen
Latifah oh you are an embarrassment
today oh who is it then is it uh it's uh
if it was today it would be Tiffany
haddish if it was like five years ago it
would have been
um can't believe you don't know the
answer to this uh hip-hop character
no it's Wanda no it's not Wanda all
right ten years ago would've been Wanda
uh uh five years ago it would have been
the the one I I can't believe hitting or
no
uh give me a hint I can't believe you
don't know the hit beloved picture of
Madagascar all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
lay it down for you it's so easy
she could star in GI Jane too oh it is
Jada Pinkett Smith is in
Madagascar it's all connected what so it
all started with punching zebras oh
that's right there we go we punched the
zebra from Madagascar because he
wouldn't keep the hippo's name out of
his fridge anymore yeah so we call Jada
oh it's heavy here throwing out jokes is
worse
I guess I would stand by the hippo one
more because you would just look at her
and be like what if you didn't get the
joke you would just think the joke makes
no sense
and then we'll see you soon
Taraji P Henson would have played her
five years ago who plays the hippo and
if Madagascar was made again two years
from now
all right I was like maybe all right we
did it it's Jada Pinkett Smith and all
of the madagascars
all the mainstream canonical like
Madagascar Madagascar popped up is not
the straight to video ones the only one
who popped up is
um that's fine that's fine shade of
Pinkett man what's her character's name
Gloria Gloria
all right this video is done see
[Music]